Like it or not, the holidays will inevitably
end — and life will crash back into its
normal routines, with all its jobs and stress
and winter chores.
"Always winterize your pipes."
So relax a little and enjoy some of Netflix's
newest releases.
January sees the addition of some incredible
new programming to ring in the New Year.
Here's what's in store for January 2018, starting
with the Netflix originals.
Glacé: Season 1
If you liked the French show Les Revenants,
you're bound to fall in love with Netflix's
newest French offering, Glacé.
Also known as The Frozen Dead in English,
Glacé is set high in an isolated mountain
range, where a police officer stumbles across
a small-town mystery that's been kept in the
dark for years.
Look for it January 1st.
Lovesick: Season 3
Considering that this show's original release
title was Scrotal Recall, you can get a pretty
clear idea of what kind of humor to expect.
The story starts when Dylan finds out he has
an STD and decides to visit every girl he's
been with to warn them about it.
"How've you been."
"I have chlamydia"
"Terrific!"
The show originally aired on the UK's Channel
4 in 2014, and Netflix began airing it as
an original with the second season.
Check out Season 3 of Lovesick when it drops
on January 1st.
Before I Wake
Directed by Mike Flanagan, Before I Wake is
about a couple's newly adopted son who has
the uncontrolled ability to manifest his dreams
in the real world.
Haunted by real-life nightmares, the couple—played
by Kate Bosworth and Tom Jane—have to figure
out why their little orphan boy is inadvertently
unleashing his night terrors on the world.
Before I Wake was filmed in 2013, but the
release date was continually pushed back until
the movie was dropped from Relativity's release
schedule altogether.
Netflix acquired the film's international
rights in 2017 and proceeded to release the
film everywhere except in the United States,
but the wait is finally over.
Before I Wake will hit U.S. Netflix on January
5th...five years after it was made.
Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee
Jerry Seinfeld's Emmy-award winning web series
has been running since 2012, and it's making
the move to Netflix as part of Seinfeld's
massive, jillion-dollar deal with the streaming
service.
Rebranded as a Netflix original, the series
is about...well, exactly what it says on the
box: comedians hang out in a car, getting
coffee.
Then, they talk about things, and it's hilarious.
If somehow you've missed this show over the
years, you'll be able to catch up on every
episode on January 5, along with 24 brand
new episodes available only on Netflix.
DEVILMAN crybaby: Season 1
An adaptation of one of the most violent,
gratuitous mangas of the '70s, Devilman: Crybaby
is easily one of the most hotly anticipated
anime releases of the new year.
The story centers on a boy who merges with
a demon to become Devilman in the hopes of
stopping Hell from taking over the Earth.
In their review of the first three episodes,
Anime-Now basically described the show as
a mature version of the Looney Tunes.
Buckle in for the ride on January 5th.
Rotten
This six-part documentary series dives into
the global food industry to take a look at
modern farming practices and the impact they're
having on the world.
Rotten promises to dig into corruption in
agricultural businesses, food additives, and
all the other hot button food issues.
Whether it hits or misses, there's one thing
you can count on: a ton of terrible Rotten
Tomatoes puns once the reviews start rolling
in.
Check it out for yourself on January 5th.
Alejandro Riaño Especial de stand up
The first new comedy special to hit Netflix
in the new year is Alejandro Riaño Especial
de stand up, which will see the Colombian
comedian taking the stage to deliver his unique
brand of rapid-fire jokes.
Take a look on January 6th.
Disjointed: Part 2
The first season of Kathy Bates' stoner comedy
Disjointed wasn't exactly a smoking success,
at least where critics were concerned.
The story centers on Ruth Feldman, a Los Angeles
dispensary owner with a team of vaguely competent
"budtenders," one of whom is her own son.
The first ten episodes were released August
25th, and Netflix is set to roll out the rest
of the season on January 12, 2018.
Somebody Feed Phil
No, this isn't a resurgence of Viva la Bam.
Somebody Feed Phil is a travel and cooking
show following Phil Rosenthal, the creator
of Everybody Loves Raymond and self-proclaimed
foodie, as he travels around the world tasting
the best cuisine the planet has to offer.
Rosenthal is no stranger to culinary travels
— he previously starred in the similar series
I'll Have What Phil's Having, which is also
available on Netflix.
Check out Somebody Feed Phil on January 12th.
The Polka King
Based on the real life story of Jan Lewan,
a polka personality who concocted a Ponzi
scheme that stole somewhere in the neighborhood
of $10 million, The Polka King is a new Netflix
original film starring Jack Black.
The feature film draws from the 2009 documentary
The Man Who Would Be Polka King, which is
also arriving on Netflix on January 12th.
You can't stop the polka.
Tom Segura: Disgraceful
Veteran stand-up comic and podcaster Tom Segura
is arriving with an all-new special on January
12th, marking his third full-length special
on Netflix.
If it's anything like Segura's other stand-up,
Disgraceful will be full of his sharp wit,
low-key delivery, and completely irreverent
topics.
Find out on January 12.
Katt Williams: Great America
Comic legend Katt Williams has been making
audiences laugh since well before he became
a household name in 1999.
In 2018, he's still going strong.
His newest special, Great America, arrives
on January 16.
Tiempos de guerra: Season 1
Translating to Times of War, Tiempos de guerra
is an upcoming scripted Spanish series set
during the Spain-Morocco War of 1921.
The show show follows the nurses and doctors
of a hospital tasked with treating wounded
soldiers, so get ready for lots of historical
drama.
You can start watching on January 18th.
Grace and Frankie: Season 4
Over three seasons, viewers have been delighted
by the escapades of Grace and Frankie, which
follows two women who find out that their
husbands have been having an affair for the
past 20 years...with each other.
"Saul and I are in love."
"Excuse me?"
"You're gay?"
"We want to get married."
"Oh…"
"Married!?"
"Because we can do that now"
"I know!
I hosted the fundraiser."
Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda star as the leading
ladies, with Sam Waterston and Charlie Sheen
as their ex-husbands.
Queue up Season 4 on January 19th.
The Open House
Not to be confused with the 2010 bomb Open
House or the 1987 cult horror B-movie of the
same name, The Open House is a 2018 horror
film about a mother and son who move into
a new house — only to find their lives threatened
by mysterious forces.
The Open House sees yet another Netflix collaboration
with actor Dylan Minnette, who also starred
in 13 Reasons Why.
The Open House, well, opens on January 19th.
Todd Glass: Act Happy
Todd Glass entered the national consciousness
with his appearances on NBC's reality show
Last Comic Standing, and he's since gone on
to make a name for himself as one of the funniest
comedians in the business.
Look for his newest special, Act Happy, on
January 23.
Ricardo Quevedo: Hay gente así
Netflix has been loading up on foreign acquisitions
lately, and 2018 will see a wave of new multilingual
comedians like Ricardo Quevado, a Colombian
native who was featured on Comedy Central's
Stand-Up Without Borders.
Now, he's hitting Netflix with Hay gente así.
Check it out on January 24.
A Futile and Stupid Gesture
National Lampoon gave us such comedy gems
as Animal House and Vacation, along with more
questionable gems like, uh, everything else
they made.
"Get ready for… Van Wilder: Freshman year."
But there's no doubt the magazine and its
films have made a lasting mark on popular
culture.
That's the angle of A Futile and Stupid Gesture,
a film about the early days of the national
sensation and its eventual downfall.
Check it out on January 26.
Dirty Money
Along with their food exposé Rotten, Netflix
is also releasing a documentary investigation
into the world's largest corporations.
Created by Alex Gibney, who won an Oscar for
his documentary Taxi to the Dark Side, Dirty
Money will be an episodic series with multiple
documentarians taking the helm for different
episodes.
Take a look on January 26th.
One Day at a Time: Season 2
Loosely based on the series of the same name
that first aired in 1975, One Day at a Time
follows a family with three generations living
under the same roof as they try to make their
lives work.
Following solid reviews for the first season,
released in 2017, Netflix announced plans
to release a second season in 2018.
All 13 new episodes drop on January 26.
Babylon Berlin: Seasons 1 & 2
Set in the 1920s, this German-language drama
follows a police commissioner who's transferred
to Berlin to investigate the Russian mafia.
Touted as the most expensive German show ever
produced, Babylon Berlin enjoyed strong ratings
in Germany, and Netflix secured the US distribution
rights well before the first episode aired.
Both seasons will drop on Netflix on January
30.
That covers all the Netflix originals.
Now let's take a look at everything else arriving
on Netflix in January 2018.
New movies
Oscar season arrives early on Netflix, with
multiple award-winners and nominees slated
to land on the service in January 2018.
On the first of the month, look out for dramas
such as The Godfather trilogy, The Shawshank
Redemption, Midnight in Paris, and Training
Day.
"King Kong ain't got s--- on me."
On the action front, the first of the year
also sees the addition of most of the Batman
films, starting with 1989's Batman all the
way to 2005's Batman Begins.
Yup, even Batman & Robin.
"If I must suffer, humanity will suffer with
me."
Plus, go ahead and let that holiday spirit
linger a little longer with the second best
Christmas movie written by Shane Black — Lethal
Weapon and all its sequels land on January
1st.
In the same spirit, Christmas may be over,
but there's never a bad time of year to experience
the ups and downs of Richard Curtis' modern
classic Love Actually.
That arrives on Netflix on January 1st, along
with other comedies like Wedding Crashers,
Caddyshack, and the Bring It On pentology.
Yeah, they made five of those.
If you're making it a resolution to watch
more documentaries in 2018, Netflix as you
covered there too.
The first of the month sees the addition of
2017 documentaries like AlphaGo, Maddman:
The Steve Madden Story, and Martin Luther:
The Idea that Changed the World.
Netflix's kids' line-up is geared toward the
whole family this January.
"The suspense is terrible.
I hope it'll last."
New Year's Day heralds the addition of the
1971 classic Willy Wonka & the Chocolate Factory,
along with 2007's Stardust, based on the Neil
Gaiman novel of the same name.
And on the 31st, Disney/Pixar's Cars 3 will
be available for streaming.
Finally, the weather won't be the only thing
giving you chills this January.
Netflix is adding a handful of thrillers to
their service as 2018 rolls through the door,
including 30 Days of Night, The Exorcism of
Emily Rose, and Peter Jackson's slow-burning
The Lovely Bones on the first of the month.
As January continues, you can look forward
to The Conjuring on the 8th and the 2017 shark-fest
47 Meters Down on the 10th.
New television
While most of Netflix's new television offerings
in January will be Netflix originals, you'll
still be able to find new seasons of some
shows.
Highlights include Season 3 of Eastsiders
on the 1st, all five seasons of Episodes on
January 6th, and Season 2 of Colony on the
12th.
Also, keep an eye out for the 2018 Olympic
Winter Games Preview on January 15, and Season
4 of Friday Night Tykes on the 17th.
Finally, January 28th heralds the arrival
of The Ministry of Time, a Spanish language
time-travel adventure series.
No matter what you're in the mood to watch
this January, you're bound to find something.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!